at a crowded rally in Charleston earlier
today former South Carolina governor U.N
Ambassador Nikki Haley she officially
launched her 2024 presidential campaign
she was speaking to a crowd of
supporters she hit back against claims
that America is a racist country
highlighting her immigrant background
take a look
we'll know better
for me the first minority female
governor in history America is not a
racist country
[Applause]
when asked about her announcement the
only other announced candidate for
presidency in 2024 for the Republicans
president Trump said quote the more the
merrier but of course the left wasted no
time attacking her The Daily Beast
columnist one of them went as far as to
call her quote another token Whoopi
Goldberg yesterday launching an attack
on The View this is what she said
you're just finding out that there are
things about our country that are not
perfect and for us to pretend that it is
and that nothing happened is ridiculous
so you're not saying anything new
I knew of all people should know better
because you used to actually have some
sanity and knew right from wrong yes and
then you lost your mind and went in some
new Direction
all right Nikki Haley now joins us with
the latest on our newly launched
campaign for president well I guess you
lost the ladies of the view they won't
be voting uh for you uh in the upcoming
primary
um let's talk about right now there's
only one other announced candidates a
lot of names being floated out there you
got into this campaign
you know if you had to delineate where
say you and president Trump differ on
issues where would you start
well first let's say in reference to
Whoopi
um you know the thought of me getting
into the race makes the Liberals heads
explode and so I welcome it because it
shows we're doing something right you
know when it comes to what we're looking
at now listen to the first 20 minutes of
your show look at everything that's
wrong in this country and tell me we
don't need new leadership but the
difference is we need new generational
leadership we have to leave the status
quo we have to leave this chaos behind
and we've got to start talking about the
future you need a Washington Outsider
that's going to come in and say it's yes
I understand that families are having to
pay more to make their grocery bill I
understand that they are worried about
their children who may never get back
from what they lost during covet I
understand the fact that when someone's
Factory leaves town he's worried that
his future went with it I understand
that you should not have Americans
looking up at the sky and seeing a
Chinese spy balloon looking back at them
this is insanity and what we need are a
lot lot of changes first of all we've
got too many politicians in D.C that are
past their Prime we have to have term
limits in Congress we need to see
competency tests for any elected
official over the age of 75. we've got
to stop the spending addiction that is
happening that is causing inflation to
go up and we need to start realizing
that we don't need our politicians
getting on TV and talking we need the
people in DC doing and we need to spark
a fire up under them and that's what I'm
willing to do and if you are tired of
losing because we've lost the last seven
out of eight popular votes for president
we're doing something wrong if you're
tired of losing then join me and go to
nikkihaley.com because we are going to
go and fight for a strong and proud
America again are you saying that the
reason Republicans lost the popular vote
I mean we have an electoral college vote
system for the very reason
that big cities like New York and big
cities in New Jersey and Chicago and Los
Angeles San Francisco won't be deciding
presidential elections are you saying
that if you are the nominee you believe
you can win the popular vote outright
I know I can I know that you will see
that we will get people that will come
into our fold our goal is not we are not
about compromises we are not about
um changing who we are we're about
fighting boldly for what we believe but
convincing our opponents to be with us
and that's the part that's going to
change we need to expand our tent we
have to bring Hispanics in we have to
bring the Jewish community in we need to
bring the Asian community and we need to
bring African Americans in because our
policies are right our policies are good
we focus on lifting up everybody not
just a select few but we have to start
talking in a way that brings people in
and that's what we can do and a lot of
that has to do with the fact that DC is
broken it's been broken for a long time
we have to have the courage to walk away
from the status quo walk away from all
the past problems and say we are not
going to leave this country to our
children we're going to make sure that
we leave our country better for our
children because they deserve it and you
could see thousands of people in South
Carolina and around the country agreed
with us today let me go back to my
original question though because anybody
that is looking or seeking a nomination
it's you're going to be comparing and
contrasting your policy positions your
views what direction you want to take
the country with your competitors uh
right now there's there's former
president Trump is the only other
candidate for the nomination we expect
many others maybe even Mike Pompeo was
on earlier in the program today where do
you see if you see policy differences
beyond what you mentioned which are
generational differences what what
specific policy areas would you would
you say part with Donald Trump
what I am saying is I don't don't kick
sideways I'm kicking forward Joe Biden
is the president he's the one I'm
running against and what I'm saying is
you don't have to be 80 years old to be
president we don't need to have these
same people going back again we need
something new we need a new generation
of Fighters we need people that
understand whether you're American your
average American is coming from and we
shouldn't be afraid to fight for that
and that's what I'm willing to do I'm
not going to kick sideways I don't have
time for that that's not my focus I'm
kicking forward it's all about Joe Biden
and it's all about the people in America
winning again and that's why we want
everybody to go to nikkihely.com because
we're in this to Win It all right uh
Governor we're going to be following
obviously this race has now begun we'll
we'll follow it every step of the way
we'll hope you'll come back thanks for
being with us tonight congratulations
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else